this is jocko podcast number 345 with
echo charles and me jacqueline good
evening ecko good evening
so just got back from an event at
echelon front that's something that we
call the council
and what is we have a small group of
about 20 leaders
we do it out in a very remote location
in
northeast washington state
and it's
an opportunity to really
get in depth with some leadership tools
with some high-level leaders that are
running in most cases very large
organizations
and when i was up there i just
wanted to share some of what i talked
about while i was there and actually
one specific
idea that i first conceptualized
at the council last year 2021 so in 2021
i went up there and essentially what
happened was it was a pretty interesting
dynamic i get up there and
we're sitting down it's a small group
there's like 15 or 20 people there
and
leif was telling a story about
us being overseas or us going through
training and he kind of told a story
where i came it came in at some point
and made like a leadership decision and
boom it helped solve whatever the
scenario was and then andrew paul was up
there and andrew paul told the story
that was something was going on and then
i came in and kind of made some decision
and and then late told another one and
so for whatever reason they both told a
couple stories each
that were illustrating some leadership
point and
the in the stories they they it made me
look like this decisive good leader
which is cool great and you know but of
course you know we're all telling
stories about each other but a couple of
the leaders that were there
after this one session
they approached me and they they said
something along the lines of you know
you just have such great
natural leadership
instincts
and of course my ego is immediately like
oh hell yeah right oh yeah yeah of
course
and then you know so we had a quick
conversation and they just said oh so
it's so nice it's so cool to hear these
stories where you have these leadership
instincts and i said yeah you know it's
pretty cool i'm pretty cool you know
kind of that ego uh idiot idiocy
and then as i
thought about it and we were on a break
and as i thought about it
it was actually a break at the end of
the day as i thought about i thought
well that's
that's actually not cool at all because
if my leadership
is just some natural instinct
then that implies
that it's something that i can't teach
you right i can't teach you i can't i
can't teach you something that is only
instinctive
so
as i thought about it i also realized
not only is that bad
but i also realized that there was
plenty of times in my life where
especially when i was younger and i
didn't have much experience as a leader
where i
didn't make good decisions or i didn't
even realize i needed to make a decision
and so as i'm sitting there thinking
about this during this break i realized
that i had learned
to lead and i had developed knowledge
and and developed kind of a process that
was so embedded in my brain that it
seemed like instinct and when these guys
hear the story it seems like instinct
but it's not instinct it's it's more of
a process
and so i sat in my room
and
i went through and just sort of wrote
down the process that i use the things
that i think about when i'm making a
decision and i
and since then i've implemented that and
teach it an echelon front
and i've added a couple things to it
since that time frame and we basically
call it the extreme ownership leadership
loop
and the reason is because extreme
ownership the book that leif and i wrote
kind of that that term just kind of
encompasses the broad
principles that
we try and operate by
and there's a reason that i use the term
loop the reason i try to use the term
loop is clearly taken from the ooda loop
observe orient decide an act
and
when you are
making a decision you can utilize
that loop
observe orient decide and act and what
that means is uh real quick brief on
that first of all you observe means you
look around and see what's happening
then you orient you you see where you
are in that
in what you have observed then you
decide what you should do and then you
act on it
and once you've acted you go back to
looking around and see how your actions
impacted what's happening and then you
orient yourself inside this new picture
and you decide what you should do now
and then you act again you just keep
running this loop
and
every time you take an action
it's going to
change the situation a little bit and
then you have to observe that feedback
orient yourself and with that new
feedback and then you make another
decision and
this becomes a little loop that you run
over and over again and it comes from
flying jets and in combat and dog fights
and it's a way that you win and the way
that you win is by making this
making decisions
and observing and orient yourself
deciding what you can do and acting
faster than the other person can do it
and if you can do that you'll win and
this also applies to jiu jitsu
obviously so
that's a loop that you need to run when
it comes to making decisions and this is
a similar process
to apply in this
in this leadership decision
loop
that i think through
when i'm trying to make a decision and
again it a lot of times it seems like
it's just some instinct
but there's there's a thought process
behind it and listen the ooda loop
for the most part
the ooda loop i view it as more of a
tactical decision
in a physical realm
against
an enemy or a competitor it's it's sort
of a an interaction between you and
someone else
in a physical and in usually in a
physical domain whether it's fighter
whether it's tactical maneuver on the
battlefield that's why it's so
applicable to combat because in combat
you're going against another person so
there's
as you as you decide and act that's
going to cause a reaction that you have
to then
calculate
into your new observations into your new
orientation and so the ooda loop really
is about
it it takes place in the physical realm
for the most part
this this loop that i'm talking about
this this eo this extreme ownership
leadership loop it's usually
i shouldn't say usually not about
physical decisions it's but it's it's
equally applicable
to
conceptual
ideas or conceptual plans or and this is
important
about human interaction that's not
physical it's
it's more the
conflict of
ideas so
one loop is in my mind more of something
that takes place in the physical realm
this
eo leadership loop takes place more in
the conceptual realm does that does that
make sense yeah fully like a in a social
verbal
all that you know right
um
and what this loop
does is it provides a checklist
or a framework of things to consider
while making a decision and listen
when you first hear this there's a bunch
of them a bunch of things to think about
and
what's weird is i had been doing this
for so long that it seemed to other
people and really to me
as instinct
and it wasn't until i said wait a second
is this really instinct or is this
something i learned well i know i used
to not have it therefore it can't be
instinct i must have learned it what
exactly am i thinking what am i
considering when i'm out there trying to
make a decision in a leadership
situation
so
let's talk through some of these things
and there's a whole bunch of dynamics
going on here
and i don't want to simplify this to a
point where you go oh
this is just a checklist here's the 19
or 14 or whatever number of things and
you just follow this checklist because
each one of these things
is a conceptual item
there's a big difference between a
conceptual idea and a physical thing
because the physical thing is in this
position it has this mass it has this
weight it has this this uh takes up this
place
in the world
an idea
a concept a plan
by its very nature is fluid
so all these things for the most part
are somewhat fluid
now there's something about the first
thing that i think about when i'm making
some kind of a decision that's actually
not fluid at all and that's why it's
number one
and that is time
that's the number one thing i think
about the the first thing that i
consider when i'm making a decision is
time
because and the reason is because this
is the one thing that's not fluid it it
is what it is
it is what it is and you can't stop it
can't stop it you know talking to
carrie helton sure you know him kw k dog
that's right
he was talking about marine corps boot
camp and he had a good little uh
hint for anybody that's going through
something tough
and his the thing that he thought about
was
these drill instructors
that they might be all powerful in
marine corps boot camp they are all
powerful near-god-like figures okay but
guess what they can't stop the clock
and no one can stop the clock
and
i you us we we have no influence
over time
we we do have influence over actions
clearly but we don't have influence over
time that clock is going to keep going
yeah
look you can you can uh
you can get ahead of it by working hard
by thinking ahead and that's why it's
the first thing that i think about
once but you can't stop it no matter
what
that's why i can't stand being late
that's why
when
going to the airport i'm going to show
up early i look not crazy early
but i'm going to show up early enough
that nothing is going to make me panic
nothing is going to make me agitated the
tsa dude's taking his time cool i got
time
and you ever notice when you're late for
something everything goes against you
yeah yeah right it feels like it happens
if you're if you're on time
green lights
yeah if you're late red lights
not like that but weird red lights
right anomalous
how long is a red light when you're late
that thing is forever it's true but the
weird thing is it's the same it's just
that you're different
your mentality is different
i tell you that story about the other
day
speaking of like
mentality so
i was at rei
aria the store yeah yeah yeah sports
store is good so i'm in rei
and i got a sprinter sure vehicle it's a
good vehicle four-wheel drive sprinter
no big deal and and i get it okay so do
you know that sprinters are a thing do
you know that i know that now yes yeah
their thing my wife told me that when
she saw yours yep and not only are they
a thing
there's a there's also a big negative
uh
perception of them because they're
expensive
and
people like drive them around
and they
and they're into people that might have
sprinters
might be into
sort of
outdoors type sports
and a lot of times people that are in
outdoors type sports are don't have a
ton of money
right so hey look at rock climbing
right rock climbing camp 4 yosemite the
their actual name for themselves is
dirtbags
hey we don't have money we live in a
little freaking toyota corolla
we sleep in a tent like that's what
they're doing yeah so you get those kind
of people you get surf bums
right you and i have talked about the
fact that bums
is a lifestyle there's a bunch of them
surf bombs jiu jitsu bums rock climbing
bums ski bums so there's a bunch of bums
right well all of those lifestyles can
also include
people that might drive sprinters the
bougie the booze
of the group the bougie people right
so i'm a bougie person i guess because i
got a sprinter yes and guess what i like
to surf i like to ski i go to yosemite
right so i do those things
so i'm at rei to pick up a bicycle
sure and as i'm pulling out
i'm leaving and by the way i'm in no
rush whatsoever time is on my side i i'm
listening to a an audiobook
i'm totally chill i don't have to it was
i i think
we weren't recording that day i had done
like a couple calls in the morning for
echelon front
i was in no rush just just kind of
enjoying like i was working in the
morning and i was it was like a nice
little a little mini vacation to be
honest with you driving towards you know
go to rei you get up there you get to
look around see some cool gear nice yeah
so i'm that's my mindset
just cruising by the way it's midday
this isn't the weekend this is like on a
tuesday or something there's no there's
no there's no panic at all no one's even
in there it's it's like it's after
i'll tell you how clear this was it's
after like the lunchtime rush on tuesday
yeah complete chill that's nice so as
i'm pulling out
and i won't try to explain the whole
thing but there's like a three-way
intersection in the parking lot
and i'm
so i back out my sprinter
and there's another truck that i'm now
head-to-head with
he wants to go right to get out i want
to go left to get out
and in comes
a little a little volkswagen
vanigan
synchro okay so what this is this is a a
four-wheel drive
volkswagen van
very rare
very cool like one of the coolest v it's
a very good i don't think it's one of
the coolest vehicles in the world but
it's it's definitely in my top
that's a cool vehicle they're super rare
so synchro that's a four-wheel drive
van
oh yeah
yeah i love vans so
which is why i have a sprinter yes sir
so
i see this van and i'm kind of like oh
dude that's a sick you know four wheel
drive
synchro van that's super rare
they're hard to get
and
the the truck
wants to go right he goes right i'm like
cool you know that guy's being cool he
he or i give him like the little hand
wave right hey cause i'm super chill by
the way i'm looking at this cool synchro
yeah so i give the guy a hand wave in
the truck i'm like hey man go ahead so
he pulls out
and then i think that the
the synchro wants to make a right
so i look at him i give him the hand
wave just like hey man come on no yeah
and i was all you know the next hand
signal would have been thumbs up i might
have even i may have even rolled down
the window
and said like sweet ride
that's a sweet ride man respect props
yeah
i give him the hand signal like yeah go
ahead man you can make the right turn
and then i'll get out after you you know
you get head of the line privileges but
you go first
let him go and guess what he does
he starts freaking you know of course
behind the wind's chin i can't hear what
he's saying gets starts going crazy on
me like like
he's like he's yelling and and what he
was basically saying was he wanted me to
move because the parking space i just
pulled out of he had pulled into and by
the way there was multiple parking
spaces
there was no factor
but man he was mad
and he was like getting all hostile and
like doing this to me and i was just
like and of course what i did smiled at
him and waved at him anyways i didn't
give him props for a synchro so if
you're listening nice synchro brom and
and i hope your syncro
and the fact that you have a cool
vehicle like that i hope that it
soothes your soul a little bit because
he's an older dude too
he was at least my age
he wasn't a spring chicken and there's
no reason for him to be stressed out on
a tuesday at
at 1300 or 13 30 in the afternoon at rei
no reason man
no reason
so
in his mind whatever was happening for
the time factor was a problem for me it
was no factor
but you can't get that stuff back you
can't adjust time
so we have to stay
ahead of time so when i'm making a
decision the first thing that i'm going
to assess
is how much time do i have here's
another thing
how fast are things changing
that's a time factor
you have to look at okay i see things
are changing but how fast are they
changing because if they're changing
rapidly
i might have to decide quicker if
they're changing slowly
well maybe i can take a little bit more
time
are there things that i can do to buy
myself more time
i know i said we can't control time but
you can't do things that can
earn you some time back
maybe there's an iterative step that i
can take
that will slow things down a little bit
on my side again i can't stop the clock
clock but i can slow them down
so
so that's what i'm going to do
i don't have any control over time and
i'm going to think about that
i'm going to consider it
the number one element in my calculus is
time and here's something else that i i
realize
some human beings have a better sense of
time than others
this is just a thing
some human beings
are more aware of time than others there
are people that are late habitually
right yes do we know this we do actually
somebody at the council asked me like
hey how do you do with echo being late
all the time and i had to give them the
information that you're actually not
i think you've only been literally late
once or twice before recording the
podcast yeah
yeah it's once or twice now do you cut
it down to
literally 32 seconds and actually if we
included when you are maybe like 45
seconds late yeah we might have to add
to that number but there's no
time there's a very small number of
actual violations
but there's there are some people that
are late all the time
there are people that think that things
are going to take five minutes and they
take 20 and that's how they see time
yeah
and so they're late all the time so if
you're one of those people and this is
gonna be a constant theme if you're one
of those people and you know that you
don't
understand time and you don't pay
attention to time
the worst you are with time if you're a
person that's that's habitually late
you this should not only be the number
one thing in your decision making it
should be number one
and it should be printed in bold large
font
so that you make sure that you get it
now listen i'm actually good with time
yeah
in fact sometimes i'm even too good with
time and i'll tell you exactly what i
mean by that
sometimes
if i think
let's say uh
let's say we were going to record the
podcast at 10 o'clock
and
i was like okay
in order to record the podcast at 10
o'clock i got to leave it 9 30. that
gives me a half an hour to get here it
only takes
15 minutes to get here tops
unless
something wild happens or i hit every
single red light or something so i might
be like oh
i need to take out the garbage right now
but that's going to take me
an extra two minutes and there's a
.0001 percent chance that i hit every
red light and now that two minutes that
it took me to take out the garbage now
i'm late so i didn't take out the
garbage so sometimes i have to
consciously say yes i can fit this in
yes i can get that done and that that is
a good thing to do but
i i'm
almost never late
i would say never but of course i'm sure
there's been some time in the last
50 years where i was late for something
but i'm almost never late
and
probably
and what i think is that's because of
this loop that i run in my head i always
think about time first and that so the
reason i'm never late is because i think
about this all the time
so know yourself
and if you're a person that constantly
underestimates how much time it'll take
to do something
know yourself
understand your own bias and this is
actually one of the things loop is
understanding your own biases this is
where you got to run that and make sure
that
you're going to have enough time to do
something
um jack yeah fully and um regardless of
my
record of not being late very much here
i am one of those people
i underestimate how did you put it i
underestimate how much time i have how
much overestimate yeah
overestimate how much time you have
underestimate how much time something is
going to take yes
interestingly
if we were to talk about how often you
were late for jujitsu yeah that's a big
number yeah that's a big number the
majority yeah it was weird
actually in the beginning when uh um
when i was coming up i was never late
but
and i think you're the one who said this
to me kind of bluntly long time ago
where
you said something like oh it's because
you don't think it's important or
something like this but and i realized
it's true
even though most of the time i wouldn't
admit that admit that to the person that
i'm late with or whatever the entity or
whatever
when i worked in the nightclub i was
late most of the time and i'm not saying
and i'm not saying like you know i was
supposed to be there at six and i was
there at like 6 30. it wasn't that it
was like in 601 603 how about 608 608
from time to time you know as you get up
past five minutes late it was less but
but
you it not being important for
like that was literally the case and not
to say my job wasn't important i'm not
saying that i'm saying the fact of me
being
ahead of time or before six o'clock that
wasn't important to me if i was one two
three four five minutes late that was
fine with me
for this reason now that i analyze it
because i could be doing
more important things than
in that five minutes you know or in that
one minute or in that two minutes kind
of a thing kind of a thought i had in my
head and now
most more important things
taking a nap you know picking watching
stuff that the way i saw it was um and
this is me totally analyzing it mentally
well i didn't this wasn't in my mind the
whole time like oh yeah this this tv
show is way more important than me it
wasn't like that it was just as it turns
out that
like dang why would i
essentially go
to where i have to be kind of a thing
when i want to do this and i don't have
to be there i don't have to be there at
6 59 or 5 59.
one of my seal buddies when i was going
to college
there was another seal that was on
going to college as well
and
we actually made a deal
because in order to in order to be on
time for something you because of
parking at this particular college and
eventually i figured out that i would
just throw my bike my bike in the back
of my
van
and just whip you know whip the bike out
and bike to all the class park park way
away from campus and just jump on my
bike and drive or ride the bike but
when we would be studying together
and we'd be like hey we'll study it you
know i'll meet you at nine o'clock to
study
we did this a few times and then
eventually and you know he was like a
guy like me married with kids so we
didn't want to if we didn't have to
be at campus we didn't want to be there
not to mention jiu jitsu not to mention
surfing so there's a bunch of other
things we'd all rather be doing so we
made a deal i was like hey i'll see you
around nine
and he was like yeah because that way if
you rolled up and you took you an extra
four minutes to find parking you weren't
like dude yeah because the only way to
ensure you weren't gonna be four minutes
late
was to be a half an hour early oh yeah
you see what i'm saying yeah the only
way to it cost you 26 minutes yeah of
life in order to ensure that you weren't
gonna be four minutes late and so we
were like hey listen around nine and we
actually had the conversation because
both of us squared away like hey being
late is the worst thing in the world and
we made a agreement a gentleman's
agreement that in this particular
scenario you had
you had slack yes and when you got there
you got there it wasn't going to be 20
minutes late but it was going to be four
minutes it might give me six minutes it
might be three minutes so we had that
little
gentleman's agreement so the target is
nine
yeah target is nine and
i'll be there yeah and if you're not
there i know 100 why it's because you
weren't going to leave 26 minutes
earlier to be there on time because it
didn't make sense because i'd rather he
was with his kids or he was surfing or
he was doing jiu jitsu actually but
he i knew he was doing something that
was more important than sitting and
waiting for me to show up to prove that
we could both be on time yeah so that
that's interesting how you say or that's
an interesting concept because that's
essentially the agreement i made with my
work yeah
they didn't make that agreement but i
did too where it's like hey i'm not
going to give up because it was the same
kind of scenario where you have to look
for parking sure you could pay for
parking but now what i got to pay extra
to be at work kind of a thing and i'm
not saying that's good or bad i'm not
saying that that should be the case or
shouldn't be the case i'm just saying
that's what i thought at the time so
that was the agreement in echoes yes sir
exactly right so you know downtown san
diego six o'clock p.m especially on
those thursday friday saturday scenarios
it's like that's hard to find parking or
it can be anyway
so yeah so i'd be like okay i'm gonna go
at the uh my opportune time my best time
in my line and hey if it's if i'm
struggling finding parking i'm
struggling finding parking you know
that's in your mind it was no fact the
gentleman's agreement because you would
have had leave
legitimately probably a half an hour
early to ensure 100 that you were going
to be
yeah probably a little bit more exactly
right like to ensure like the kind no
you got to be here before or six or
whatever kind of a thing to ensure yeah
it's like half an hour yeah it's like
it's not even in my mind's name fair how
about this how about this
well we'll we'll
we'll decide a reasonable amount of time
i have to leave the house how about that
and if parking is abnormally scarce or
traffic that's it we're going to pay
that price together how about that
the traffic thing is weird too because
that's an excuse that people use like oh
yeah i really hit traffic
and
if you live in california you're like
bro yeah yeah you're gonna you gotta
calculate for that come on yeah
yep i agree it's kind of not a valid
excuse unless
let's say you and i work in an office
every single day
and
we we make that agreement like hey our
goal is nine o'clock but i understand i
don't want you to leave an hour early
to make sure you get here
at that time and i go hey man
you leave your hot like you said you
leave your house before this time
reasonably i knew that there's going to
be some there could be some variables
yeah and especially if they're like the
variables really vary because like the
traffic thing in i don't know about your
roots you know in san diego whatever but
as far as the routine goes very loose
routine that i have it's i know when the
traffic is gonna be you know it's pretty
predictable yeah you know you got your
anomalous accident or some hold up on
the road every once in a great great
great while
but
so it is i
to me anyway
i think that factoring the traffic is is
a fair thing like you gotta you gotta
hey if it takes 15 more minutes on this
tuesday
after work hours yeah versus sunday
morning or whatever then that's part of
the agreement you gotta you gotta factor
that in
but
sunday morning let's say sunday morning
every time we're recording and then or
whatever we're doing and then
no traffic and then one day there's like
traffic because there's some
event at the beach or something
i do expect a little bit of uh what do
you call it leeway
okay
about that i guess so that is time
first thing you got to be thinking about
causes stress
get ahead of it
uh the next thing and this should really
come as no surprise the next things that
i think about
are
the four laws of combat leadership cover
and move simple prioritizing executing
decentralized command but i think about
them in a very particular way
so if i'm making a decision the first
thing i think about is cover and move
the number one thing is am i supporting
my teammates does this help the team
am i
putting my team first
so so i want you to think about that the
first thing i think about his time
because i have no control about the
second thing i do is make sure that i am
not putting myself ahead of the team and
i'm not making a decision that's going
to leave anyone else on the team in the
lurch
right
and this will immediately
vector you in the correct direction you
know because any time that you as a
human are making a decision
and it's based on benefiting you there's
a really good chance that that's a bad
call and from a leadership
perspective there's a huge chance as a
matter of fact i'm gonna go and say
that's a bad call
the the
the
military
term is supporting distance so echo
if i'm working with you if my fire team
or my squad or my platoon is supporting
your fire team your squad your platoon i
have to stay within a distance where i
am able to support you that means
usually my
weapons can cover where you may be
attacked from
and my
communications
can speak to you directly and generally
speaking
in a in an infantry scenario i want to
be where i can actually
see you
i can actually you know put on my night
vision or at least
pull out my you know pull out my
binoculars and see where you are go i
got him i know exactly where he is the
minute that we're out of that supporting
distance there's going to be a problem
so from like a tactical perspective
that's a great thing to think about but
from a leadership perspective
cover and move
is am i
being supportive of
the rest of my team
and if you're not
it's going to be a problem now here's a
couple things to watch out for some
people have a tendency to look out for
themselves
and some people
if they have that tendency one of the
worst things about that tendencies that
tendency is they don't think anyone else
can see it
and i'm telling you right now
when people are getting screwed they see
it
and in whatever subtle way whatever
whatever maneuver you're doing that you
think no one else can see that you're
leaving people
everyone can see it they can see it
thousand percent they can see what's
going on
so
if you think you might be a person and
this goes back to what are your own
personal balance biases
if you are a person
that goes through life that kind of
looks out for yourself
this is where you need to
index in the right direction
appropriately to make up the fact that
you're a little bit of a person that
takes care of yourself
so just just watch out for that
and the way you watch out for that is by
when you're making a decision this is
the second thing you ask yourself
am i making this decision and it's only
going to benefit me
and more important
am i supporting my teammates with this
decision that i'm going to make
and if you're not
reconsider
the next one is keeping things simple
uh
how complicated is this decision or how
much complexity will this decision add
to our situation
what
and that's really a great way to think
about it will this decision take our
current situation and simplify it if
it's going to do that that's very very
helpful
if this
decision is going to
make things more complex this is
usually not a good decision
so the minute you say oh we just need to
get some more people down here into the
mix
and all sudden you think to yourself
wait a second that's actually going to
make things more complicated
reconsider again you can still you can
hey any one of these things that i'm
saying right now
there are situations where you you have
to still push through it
it's when you're not thinking about it
it's not when you're not being
intentional about your decision that's
when you're gonna have a problem
most important when you don't even
recognize
a lot of times people are making things
more complex they don't even know it
because they're not considering the
things that i'm talking about sometimes
they're screwing people over they're not
even thinking about it that's look
there's sometimes where i'm screwing
over echo with my decision
but i don't you know i just don't think
he's gonna notice or i don't care
sometimes i'm doing it and i just i i
don't even recognize the fact that oh i
didn't realize echo was going to get
left out in the cold one time freaking
leaf babin we were staying in a hotel at
the muster and we had like
uh i had a room he had a room and they
were shoot they were
joined by um like a
a unit room or whatever like a like a
what's that word a common area yeah a
common area but actually my the the
entrance to my room
was through the common area and then so
to get into my room you'd go through the
common area and then i'd go into my room
leif had he could go into the common
area and then to his room or he could go
through the hallway
so we went to pt
and and i forget how it happened but he
locked the common area door
so and then we got split up when i came
back i didn't have the key to his room
you know that little you know like the
key the mechanical
lock on the door he had swung that thing
shut oh sorry so we were laughing uh
he was actually trying to help me out
but he locked me out of my room good
which was awesome
sir awesome he didn't know right he
didn't know that he didn't know that
we were all both gonna leave through his
room so anyways
my point is sometimes you're doing
things
and you don't understand the secondary
effects so that's one of the
that's one of the benefits of having a
checklist because the minute you say oh
wait a second the jocko might actually
have to come back in and i won't be with
him so therefore i should open the door
from the inside cool got it done
sometimes i say oh i wanted to do this
thing
oh but am i really covering for echo
no i'm not i gotta help him out okay
so this the one of the uses of running
this loop and going through this
checklist is you make sure you're not
doing something that doesn't make sense
that you didn't that you weren't aware
of
so make sure that you are covering for
the rest of your team make sure you're
putting the team first when you make a
decision
next one simple
well i already covered simple uh making
sure things aren't complicated the next
one is prioritize and execute does this
decision that i'm about to make
match the
priorities that we should be focused on
that that's a that's that's step number
one hey wait a second i'm about to go in
this direction does that even help us
getting where we want to go then you
kind of have to dig a little bit deeper
are the priorities that i'm focused on
right now are they even correct
because sometimes what you're focused on
right now
changes and you have to adapt
if you and i are rolling and i'm trying
to defend an arm lock you're trying to
unlock me and all of a sudden you get my
neck
guess what the priority is
priorities
protect your neck right
so priorities are going to change
and so you have to make sure when you
make a decision that you're supporting
the right priority or you're supporting
the priority that you have designated
and you also have to double check that
the priority that you're focused on is
the right one
or the priorities plural that you're
focused on are the right ones plural
and then once again you gotta check your
own tendencies because some people have
a tendency to get distracted
and
if you're a person that has tendency to
get distracted
then you need to double down on making
sure you focus on the right priorities
some people have a tendency to try and
accomplish too much
they have the tendency to be like
those people might usually have a also a
bad relationship with time where they
think they can do more than they have
time for and then they also say i can do
that i can do that i can do that
even though i have a good relationship
with time sometimes i do try and bite
off more than i can chew
but not very often most of the time i
don't do that most of the time i could
actually
take the garbage out before i go to
jujitsu
but i don't want to be two minutes late
so therefore i'm going to take the
garbage out later i should have taken it
out i should have rolled the dice
that there's a point zero zero one
percent that i'm
a minute and 28 seconds late
so know what your tendencies there's
people that have a tendency to shift
priorities too often similar to being
distracted right but they're like no we
need to focus on this and then three
days later no we need to focus on this
and then three days later no we need to
focus on this
that actually happens
uh and of course there's some people
that get fixated on a priority
that may or may not matter
as time goes on
so that can happen as well
so when you are making a decision check
your priority
list and make sure that your decision
supports the priority and then also
double check that the priority you're
focused on or priorities that you are
focused on are the right ones
pretty straightforward
uh decentralized command
here's a really good rule of thumb if
you're in a leadership position
the decision that i'm about to make
can i
decentralize and delegate the action
so as soon as i'm thinking of doing
something i think to myself
oh
can i
turn this over to someone else so hey we
got to get that building cleared
yes we're gonna clear that building hey
leif
grab your squad grab your platoon grab
your team go get that building clear can
i turn it over to someone else hey echo
we need to uh come up with some cool
graphics for this event that we're going
to do
can i turn that over to you i want to
know if i can because my goal is to
not be focused on doing things myself
because the minute that i'm doing
something myself i can't
look up and i can't look out
which is going to impair my ability to
lead
this also allows me to be aware and
again so much of this is awareness it
allows me to be aware that sometimes
there's something that i i do have to do
and i've got to say hey echo i've got to
go do this thing cover me
or hey echo i'm going to be going in and
executing on this thing watch my back
or look up and out while i'm doing this
so these are all things that again it's
okay to make those decisions as long as
you're aware of it but the minute i go
hey i'm gonna go execute this thing and
i don't tell you to look out now now we
get flanked
we're looking
hopefully with decentralized command
we're hoping and the goal is that we are
only doing things that only we can do
i only want to do things that only i can
do
everything else i wanna i wanna have
someone else on the team do it that's
the goal
and by the way the things that i only i
can do i eventually want to train
someone else to be able to do those
things
how do you balance the um
okay remember you know you're you're
still uh it was your story about um
somebody came to you was like you know i
need this advice or whatever and you
said put them in charge of something
they put and then that person put them
in charge of something that was really
undesirable like cleaning cleaning
cleaning toilets seal team two on the
second deck yeah that was the mission
someone was tasked with in order to give
them more responsibility right and it
didn't help the situation it made them
more bad so so how do you find the
balance because kind of in a way that
kind of in a matter of speaking
translates over to what you're talking
about now where it's like hey can i
delegate this can i delegate this which
a lot of a lot of times depending on the
project of delegation it can empower
someone it can help the whole group
because they can do this while you're
doing quote unquote more important
things or whatever how do you balance
like what you delegate them to do with
something
important or whatever versus something
that because you know some things need
to be done but no one really wants to do
it kind of a thing hey if something
sucks
i'm i'm gonna get in there and do it
somewhere this is the picking up brass
story yeah right because picking up
brass
it's real easy to say uh you know what
guys i gotta go back to uh meet with the
commanding officer i'm gonna go back and
prep a brief so i'll be back in the air
conditioned office back in san diego
while you guys are out here in 120
degree hit picking up brass
real easy to say that
so decisions like that
i'm gonna be very cautious and i'm gonna
weigh my leadership capital which we'll
get to because if look
does this mean if the commanding
officer's like hey i need a brief
tomorrow i'm like sorry sir i'm picking
up brass no
it doesn't mean that but
i better prioritize
building relationship with the troops
making sure they understand that i don't
mind getting my hands dirty don't mind
getting my knees freaking
cut up don't mind having blisters on my
hands from picking up hot brass out in
the desert uh
that's what i'm gonna do
so
there's some there's some variables that
we have to weigh into and that's also
why good deals give them away
you know hey someone's got to go ashore
early and and spend an extra four days
in
wherever this nice vacation
area of thailand yeah it's like oh my no
i'm going to go on the advantage not
like no
no hey echo you got it take these guys
make sure we have you know the stuff
that we need for the training in
thailand to do like awesome right yeah
so
that's how i weigh it out just just i
have to i have to
i have to assess the suck meter yeah and
if you're a person that always sees the
suck meter high and runs the other way
everybody knows it yeah so
don't do it so it's kind of a little
balance in that game within the game
kind of a thing 100
yeah because if you just be rigid or
this is what it seems like anyway if you
just be rigid to the hey i'm always
going to delegate and then it's when it
comes to you know
i'm going to oh trash needs to be taken
out yeah i got i got an extra three
minutes or whatever no but no no i'm
sticking to the rule delegate delegate
you know kind of a thing no things that
suck
try not to delegate
and look that could also mean if you're
the platoon commander guess what you're
doing all day
cleaning the toilets picking up brass
like you could be you could assign
yourself every task that kind of sucks
and we don't want to do that so we have
to put that into the calculus
we don't just delegate things that suck
in fact you know
life tells the story we were going
through
the our dive portion of training
and diving kind of sucks you know it's
cold wet miserable long boring
and some people think
and so a lot of guys given the
opportunity
they have meetings to attend during time
they have uh whatever reports to write
yeah and
leif
and seth you know they were kind of like
surprised here i am got my wetsuit on
got my fins out we're ready to go dive
ready to go spend four hours turtle
backing around san diego bay and making
three hours on bag
in the darkness you know bored out of
your mind but that's what you do yeah so
that's one of those things where
if it sucks
use caution while delegating
makes sense fully yeah fully it's a yeah
it's the kind of
more of the approach to it right where
it's like you got to understand the
overall picture of what you what are you
doing here you know and why are you
doing it kind of a thing so if you
if you have more important things to do
you delegate these things they're all
important because they're all pieces of
the puzzle right but um yeah you there's
another like i said game kind of going
on where
you want to be looking out for everyone
in that little additional way
you know and you're going to sacrifice
little parts of kind of yourself yeah
yeah to kind of do it
um
so
we kind of got the four laws of combat
covered the next thing i'm gonna think
about
and this is a big one
is making sure that our ego is not
driving this decision
which
you would be shocked and dismayed at the
number of decisions
that are
driven
by ego
driven by ego they're they're almost 100
in some cases driven by ego
am i making this decision based on my
ego am i imposing it as punishment
subconscious punishment on someone who
questioned me
am i forcing this to prove
to echo that my plan was the better plan
so
you have to be extremely cautious of
that
and and the thing that we have to be
careful of is that our our ego can
absolutely or not even
your ego is going to lie to you
that's what our ego does our ego is
going to lie to us and so my and and if
it's tricky too your ego's smart your
ego's
it's like the devil you ever seen the
movie the exorcist yes so in the movie
the exorcist the devil
knows the things to say to the priest
that's gonna like get him
and your ego is
equally smart as the devil
and it knows
my ego's like
hey hey jocko
this hey i know i get extreme ownership
hey i buy into extreme ownership 100
but this time is actually really is
echo's fault
echoes plants really not as good as
yours you should i get it i know you
want to be humble
but hey if you're humble now it's
actually going to cost you in the long
run that's the way your ego talks to you
it's like a
little savage in there just manipulating
so you got to be very careful that the
other thing that happens is if you if
your ego is running the decision
have you listened to anybody else
have you listened to other people with
an open mind
do you have an open mind
so be careful of that because sometimes
we're listening but we're not hearing
and then a good little sanity check am i
doing this am i using this decision am i
driving this decision
with my rank with my position
even with my experience and let me
explain what that sounds like
the idea of driving it sounds good right
it sounds good for me to say hey i'm
more experienced that's why i'm making
this decision yeah
but that's the equivalent as
dude i've been doing this for 20 years
you need to shut up and listen to me
yeah
any of those things
if the main driver
of your decision and the way you're
convincing people is through experience
or through rank or through position or
authority you you already lost
you you already let let me say you lost
but you need to reconsider what's
happening because if i can't articulate
to you echo charles why i made this
decision without saying because i
outrank you or because i'm in charge of
this or because i have because i've been
i've done this type of thing 20 times if
i have to go there that means i'm not
really
i can't articulate why we're going with
my plan and that's a problem and the
problem most likely is my ego
so use caution on that
and right tied up next to that
is emotion
am i making an emotional decision
i mean
what a
smart little thing to check on and if
you check on it
you're going to realize
that it's a bad but that is a bad move
people make emotional decisions all the
time and by the way they almost never
turn out good
am i mad am i frustrated am i
vengeful
am i fearful
am i guilty
guilt is an emotion
that'll make you do something that you
know you shouldn't do
fear is an emotion that'll make you do
something that you shouldn't do
frustration i'm getting frustrated you
know what just go ahead and do it right
these are horrible things
so
check with yourself and make sure that
your emotions are not driving the
decision now listen here's the other
thing here's the dichotomy
is your emotions do still have to be
part of the calculus
they got to be part of the calculus you
got to calculate your own emotions
to get the answer you got to calculate
the emotions of the team to get the
answer because if the team is all
mad about doing this thing and i say you
know what though logically we should do
it all right guys this is the logical
answer go do it and all it does is make
everyone matter first of all are you
going to execute well are you going to
do a good job are you trustworthy while
you're out there and you're mad what to
do to my leadership capital there's all
these problems it's going to cause
all these problems going to cost so i
have to put emotions into the calculus
but it can't be the overwhelming
driver of my decision making it has to
be a component
but it should be a small component in
most cases meaning
if i know that making some decision is
going to make the entire team totally
irate
i need to wait it a little bit more
because the emotion's stronger
but
you have to calculate it and if you're
not aware of it if you're not paying
attention to it then it's not gonna it's
not gonna work out the way you want it
to it's gonna actually
cause bad decisions
next one perspective
perspective
people throw this around
people throw this around what
makes you know what other people's
perspectives is but they only throw it
around when they think about it
but a lot of times we get locked into
our perspective
and that's bad
i want to see as many different
perspectives on a subject on a topic on
an idea that i can i want to know my
peers
perspectives i don't know my
subordinates perspectives i want to know
my superiors perspectives i want to know
my competitors or my enemies perspective
what are they actually seeing right now
the more angles
i see of a target or of a problem
the more the better i can understand it
and the better i can understand it
the better off i'm going to be
and we have this thing when you when you
do a reconnaissance of a target a
building or a compound
when you when you do it what you try and
do is you try and move around the entire
perimeter over a period of time you try
and see it from every different possible
angle
if you don't see something from every
possible angle there's something that
you're missing and that thing that
you're missing could be a critical
component of the target or of the
problem
so by asking your subordinates hey what
does this look like to you by asking
your peers like hey what do you see here
by asking your boss hey what does it
look like from your perspective
by doing that it's going to give you a
better understanding of the target of
the problem of the issue and then you
can better formulate a plan and by the
way
my default mode
is to
take when someone else says hey jocko i
see a solution my default mode is to try
and utilize their solution try and
utilize their plan try and utilize their
idea that's my default mode
now if there's a leadership vacuum and i
wrote about this in leadership strategy
tactics field manual if there's a vacuum
no one's making a decision sure i'm
going to step in
i'm going to give you some little hints
here
when there's a leadership vacuum i'm
going to let that leadership vacuum
develop it a little bit extra just a
little bit extra i'm going to let that
void let the presence of that silence of
that non-direction of that lack of
leadership i'm gonna let it sit there
for an extra
second two seconds why am i doing that
because i want everyone to know
that there's a leadership void and it
doesn't take long it takes a second
takes two seconds three seconds and all
of a sudden everyone goes oh and when
everyone knows there's a leadership void
everyone is primed to execute
everyone is ready to receive
orders
so
if there's a leadership void i'm gonna
make sure everyone can feel it by the
way those extra two three seconds i'm
actually actually confirming the plan in
my head that i've formulated so now my
plan is gonna be two or three seconds
further developed and better
and then i make the call and yes i'm
going to make a small call a iterative
decision
and if someone else
happens to make a call at the same time
guess what i'm going to do i'm going to
support their call
well because that's my default mode
my default mode is to support someone
else's call
because that is the easiest way to move
forward with a plan the easiest way to
move forward with a plan isn't with echo
has a plan and i have a plan to try and
convince echo that my plan is better
the easiest way the quickest way to move
is say echo sounds good i'm on board
what do you want me to do how can i
support
unless echo's plan is freaking
you know
horrible
actually let me rephrase that in a more
distinct way
unless echo's plan is unviable
it's an unviable plan that will not work
if it's a minimally viable plan
if it's you know if it it'll get the job
done
you have a minimally viable plan and i
have a viable plan so that means mine
might be a little bit better
but now i have to convince you of that i
have to explain why and by the way when
i say i'm gonna support your plan i can
probably bring some additional viability
to your plan that can make your plan
better than mine was in the first place
so that's what i'm gonna do
that's the easiest way to do it now
what do we need to think about here is
we need to think about the fact that we
almost all here's a bias
that almost all of us have the same bias
which is my idea is the best idea
that's that's that's our general
consideration as humans that my idea is
the best idea
so know that you have that bias i
actually go hard against that bias and
quite frankly sometimes i go too hard
against that bias sometimes someone's
got a plan i'm like
and it might not
it might be minimal really minimally
viable
sure and i'll be like you know what
we'll go with it
sometimes i do that a little bit too
much
so i know that why do you think you do
that
i just want to be supportive don't want
to be a
imposing tyrant on the team
and someone and and generally i'm like
thinking to myself well you know my
plan's good but you know we can probably
make echo's plan worth i would rather do
why i'll tell you why i literally
believe what i'm saying right now it's
usually easier for me just to support
your plan than it is for me to convince
you of this other plan and explain it to
you i can uptake your plan pretty quick
i get it cool let's go execute that
thing i'm supporting you let's run with
it
and then i'm detached from your plan so
i can see a little bit more when it's my
plan all of a sudden i gotta i gotta
manage that whole thing and i'm staring
right into it and i don't know how good
you are at being detached and trying to
adjust things you might not be as good
as me so you know what i'm gonna let you
detachment is a harder skill than
than the planning and execution
or it's a rarer skill
if i tell you to go and execute
something there's a good chance you'll
be able to do it
if i tell you hey i'm going to go
execute
you detach and sit on the outside and
try and give me some
broad guidance about how i can do better
that's a harder job because most people
most of the time you'll be like
i'm starting to execute my plan you're
going to jump in there with me and start
doing it too
so that's why i sort of over index
on allowing
on providing support or allowing people
to do things that maybe i don't know 100
agree with right i mean
you've done some stuff where i've been
like well
that didn't seem to be the best idea was
it and we can look back post-mortem
is this the christmas music thing
christmas music that's a good one right
all right
you know sure some things happen you're
like well that not good that's not what
we were looking for at all
didn't you say you didn't even know that
was a christmas song yeah that's correct
bruh i know bro i don't know sorry i do
now though so you know you got to watch
out for that one
so
that's the deal it's perspective you
have to actually
pull yourself back and try and see other
people's perspectives and the best way
to do that is by talking them asking
them good questions about what they see
you're not going to be
a freaking uh
uh what's the word
a psychic that i can see what echo sees
i don't go into a meditative state and
get and go into your brain no i go hey
echo what does that look like to you
this is not this isn't freaking this
isn't freaking uh
this isn't remote viewing
this isn't remote viewing what's the
deal with rome do you think it's true i
don't know they had big programs with it
in the military there's a movie about it
yeah i mean i don't
if it is true i don't know how it works
at all it doesn't seem it could be you
guys are really good at guessing maybe
you know
well a lot of the what do you call like
the psychic you know mediums and mind
readers and stuff that's as it turns out
from what in a sense what it is it's
like it's not guessing but it's like
guessing about like they they react to
cues with you like how you respond so
it's like i'm seeing red and then if
they do something they're like okay red
is something you know do you know a
person name and they go real basic names
first and so because i'm feeling at john
you know or jim
would be even even broader it's like
do you know anyone that's do you know
one that's experienced trouble in their
life right now and if i see you like
then i'm like wait
are they sick you know what i mean and
at the same time my mind is awake do i
then i search for everyone in my whole
it's like whether it's significant or
not you kind of make it significant so
it's like a dance going on maybe we'll
have a remote viewer on the program
because the military had like a remote
viewer
group
people that that's what they did sit in
a room and go into a meditative state
and look for
you know missile launch pads
yeah stuff like this i guess the
argument for and against it
in a matter of speaking is kind of the
same thing where it's like your brain is
so complex and we you know there's a lot
of stuff about your brain and all this
stuff that we don't know
so
it's possible but at the same time it's
kind of like all right well i don't see
how your eyes
can like see something that they don't
see and it's your brain you know like it
doesn't make sense given what we do know
it doesn't make sense eddie bravo has a
podcast now and it's called look into it
i think it's called look into it which
is a freaking great name and this makes
me think you know
maybe we need to get eddie bravo to look
into it and see what's up see what's up
with remote viewing
because he's looking into a bunch of
stuff oh yeah you know why it's called
look into it
i think it's because of what i just said
is there another reason yeah well that's
a thing that there was a um was it a
meme kind of that he
he was on a podcast i forget which one
it was but it was one you know one of
joe rogan's podcast he was on there and
then they got into this heated like
argument about
you know one of the things that eddie
bravo really kind of purports maybe
wasn't ufos what was it i don't know 911
maybe i don't know i i forget what it
was but he kept saying you just haven't
looked into it you just haven't looked
into it you know
that was kind of his defense to a lot of
things but he said it so many times that
like it became a thing well it's a great
name for his podcast because that's what
he's doing he's out there looking into
it
the weird thing about looking into
things these days is you can kind of
find what you want whatever you want
right yeah that's true there's there's
all kinds of things to find what you
want yeah to find we have this
trampoline
well yeah and
okay so we have this trampoline it's re
it's called a rebounder it's like
essentially like a regular little
trampoline but it's like
i don't know more
robust i don't know whatever it is how
big is it like the regular sized ones
like this table maybe a little bigger
that's not a regular size so when i
think trampoline i think of something
that you that is like 15 feet across
yeah yeah like a leg breaker yeah yeah
but this thing is this is like one of
those fitness translates when you jump
on it yeah exactly right but it's the
one where it's like there's no noise
it's called a rebounder i'm sticking so
anyway one of the claims is that oh yeah
it does something to your lymph system
okay like it like
does something to it elevates it somehow
makes it better you know the pressure
and
here's the thing
that could be 100 true it could be look
into it yeah you look into it so i go
and look in and you know my wife she's
like saying yeah my dad told me and this
and he has one and let's face it the
kids jump on it it's fun that's my main
kind of catalyst or whatever you didn't
even have to look
it's fun the kids freaking love it and
whatever it's good for your legs too
obviously
oh it's but i'm like
if i'm gonna talk trash which i do just
jokingly because i don't i don't know if
it helps your lymph system or not
if i'm going to talk trash i should at
least look into it so i looked into it
and sure enough
it says yeah it does this your lymph
system but then but then
just like what you're alluding to where
you kind of got to consider the source
you know and then oh what i wanted to
spend my day looking into this five
websites that said this now i got to
determine the credibility so it's like
hard you know yeah there's all kinds of
cuz you can make a website that has oh
click here for the supporting
documentation but you also wrote the
supporting documentation right right so
even when you're looking into it you're
not looking in the right place
yeah it's true man
what's what
what uh platform
is eddie bravo's do you know what it's
on a platform i don't know if it's on an
open platform oh i don't know i have to
look into it
so there you go uh
perspective
you gotta look into some other people's
perspectives
and and figure out
what the whole
target what the whole problem looks like
so there you go perspective
spend some time put that on your
checklist
the perspective you have by the way is
not the whole thing and there's a good
chance that your perspective is actually
wrong right hey i don't see any enemy on
this target all you need to do is go 90
degrees in the other direction you can
see a bunch of enemies sitting behind a
building yeah
hey make your bias
that your perspective is probably a
little bit off maybe even make your bias
that you're that you're wrong yeah that
what you see is
not the whole picture that what you see
is actually a bad picture that's what i
think of my perspective
i think uh you know what this is what i
see and i know my my gut instinct is
like i know i i'm not seeing everything
and there's more to the picture and i
need to figure out what that is make
that part of your checklist um
next thing
is mission
so so
is the decision that you're about to
make does it support the mission that
you're actually trying to
execute on and not actually more
important than that does it support your
overall strategic mission
and this is this causes all kinds of
there's a there's a term out there have
you heard their mission creep yeah yeah
it's a pretty common term now this is
because people don't run this leadership
loop in their brain and they don't ask
themselves hold on a second what's our
mission what's our overall mission and
is this in support of it if i make this
decision it's going to help us ret uh
reach our strategic goals all kinds of
people make that mistake
and we can't allow for that
so what you do is you just run a quick
check and say hold on does this support
the tactical mission that we're trying
to execute does this support the
strategic mission that we're trying to
achieve and if it doesn't you know it's
a bad decision
next one leadership capital
and this is one that i recently added to
this list and and and the reason that i
added to the list is because
at some point i was having a discussion
with somebody
and i realized
actually let me rephrase this i was
making a decision
and i realized that the main thing that
i was calculating was how much this was
gonna cost me from a leadership capital
perspective okay
and so so first of all what is
leadership capital
leadership capital is the fact that you
can only get
people to do so much
as a leader you can only get people to
do so much there's a there's a there's a
when you ask somebody to do something it
costs
it costs
you leadership capital and if they don't
want to do it it costs more
and if they want to do it then it costs
less
and if they do it on their own accord
then it's very cheap maybe even free and
if you let them do what they want you're
kind of collecting some leadership
capital
so
just the very
any interaction that i have with echo
charles if i say hey
get this done
hey hey do this hey
make a video about this that cost me
leadership capital cost me leadership
capital
especially if you don't want to do it
it is costing me even more leads now
look i might have some leadership
capital with you and you're like all
right fine i'll do it if you
want to do it
if i'm like hey make a video with robots
exploding you're like oh hell yeah right
it didn't cost me very much
now if i say to you man i wish we had
more videos with robots exploding you
were like dude i'm gonna make a sick one
that's very cheap
you're still working so maybe it cost me
a little something
but if i say hey man
i have no idea what to do what do you
think we should do and you're like we
need to make a video with robots
exploding i go that's awesome
i actually gained some leadership
capital
so everything when you're when you're
when people are interacting with each
other there's going to be leadership
capital spent
we
and by the way every interaction that i
have with you not never mind just a task
but when we interact with each other
there's
leadership
capital being exchanged
and we as people always think we have
more leadership capital
than we do
here's a couple things that will throw
you for loop you think rank gives you a
bunch of leadership capital it doesn't
it doesn't
rank it it gives you a little tiny bit
because hey man you know obviously i'm
in this position and you you haven't
been here as long as me and i've done
this stuff before so there's a an
element of leadership capital that comes
with rank
but it's not as much as we think and
actually when i give ownership to
someone
when i say hey echo you go ahead and run
this project the way you want you you
seem to you seem to have a good grasp on
it you that actually earns me leadership
capital so giving ownership
earns leader ship capital listening to
someone as simple as that might sound
gives me leadership capital when you
come to me and say i want to talk to you
about something i go oh and i get out my
notebook and i say hey tell me what you
got you said i have this idea of doing
this and i'm writing it down that gives
me leadership capital um
you could do like a little
whether it be fresh lawn front or
whatever you could do like a fun little
quiz
right and it's like leadership capital
quiz like is this spending it or earning
it right and you could do little things
you could probably go pretty deep with
that you can go real deep i've done i've
covered that in the academy how to earn
leadership capital yeah and what costs
leadership capital so
you definitely that's that's good we
could we could do it on here at some
point as well
uh
it's surprising how much listening to
people
gives you leadership capital and usually
when i talk about the
the opposite of that
is when people go oh yeah he's right
because listen if you start telling me
something i cut you off
right yes
you might not realize the weight of when
you're telling me something and i listen
to you you might not it's like a
subconscious you'd be subconsciously
giving me leadership
yeah but when i cut you off and you're
yeah confidence
trying to express something to me and i
just cut you off and i'm like yeah hey
look let's get to the topic of the day
yeah you're just that that cost me a lot
of leadership capital
um just like any and that's just just do
with respect
you know what you were talking about
earlier uh a crappy job
if if we got something if we got to go
pick up brass
and i'm out there doing it with you
leadership capital goes up if i'm in the
air conditioning place
leadership capital goes down so there's
all these things
that are going on
bro it gets kind of tricky too though
but i'm then maybe this is my little p
brain mind going too deep into it
maybe it's not but like let's say you
okay you know your story right the
patches right so you let we'll say you
let something slide right
you let some of these slides up
sometimes that
under certain circumstances that can
gain you may have you gaining leadership
capital but under other circumstances
you can lose it it's the same action
right you let something slide yeah but
it's like oh you got to understand
that's why we wrote the dichotomy of
leadership yeah that's why a quiz would
be and that's why leadership is tricky
yeah it's tricky because you you gotta
you gotta assess that and that's why i'm
talking about this this leadership loop
because so often people aren't actually
just checking themselves like wait a
second i wonder how bad echo actually
wants to do this i wonder what this is
costing me yeah
the
the reason that it weighs
so heavily for me first of all because
leadership capital is the currency of
winning if you want to win you've got to
have a bunch of leadership
capital built up
and i put so much weight on leadership
capital
because
this is interesting
thing to think about
most of the time
one idea
it's only a little bit better than some
other idea
right very rarely are you and i working
at a company or in a military unit or
part of a team
and your idea is so
radically different from mine
that i'm willing to that i even need to
think about
hey is that a good decision or not
usually your idea is pretty good
you're like in your mind you're like hey
i want to explode uh star wars robots
and i think you should explode
terminator terminator robots right
are those two things
worth arguing about
no no are they worth it they're not
i think one thing you think another
thing but the things that we're thinking
are very closely related so therefore
what trumps the idea because the ideas
are so close
what trumps the idea is leadership
capital we have a common goal we have a
common
capability we have common experiences
and we're going to come up with pretty
similar plans because we're both coming
from the same place therefore your plan
is probably going to be viable and
because your plan is viable because what
i say you want star wars
okay because you want terminator robots
and i want star wars robots
they're both viable but because they're
both viable
i make the expenditure of leadership
capital a very heavy
weighted element of my decision
because the decision between star wars
robots or terminated robot isn't going
to make that much of a difference
now are there people that freaking dig
in about what robot needs to die hell
yeah there are and they're idiots for
doing it i don't care
i don't care
and the reason i don't care is because
building leadership capital is the
strategic move
that's the strategic move because
if we're spending leadership capital all
the time we won't have any left or we'll
even worse we'll end up in debt and
that's not going to end well because by
the way when i don't have any leadership
capital with you and i ask you to do
something
you're not going to do it
if i have a ton of leadership capital
and i need you to do something
and there's no time to talk about it and
you don't believe in it but i need to
get it done i can actually spend some of
that leadership capital we can move
forward
so
that's what i'm going to do
when i'm making a decision as to whether
or not
to go left or right or use terminator
robots or star wars robots
i'm going to put a huge amount of weight
on how much leadership capital this is
going to cost me
and see and weigh
whether this is
whether this is the right move or not
most of the time
it's not
most of the time it's not
leadership capital is
more valuable
than any other element
in the world
leadership capital it's it's everything
that's
wrapped up in leadership capital
trust
integrity
vision
unity there's all these things that are
wrapped up in it and that's what makes
it so valuable it's like this this thing
that has so much power yeah and yet
people will throw it away bill don't
even realize how valuable it is i'll
just throw it away on this that or the
other thing yeah like hey echo you just
need to get this done boom i just i just
spent freaking
however many units worth of leadership
capital
dude you just need to be quiet and get
this done boom just throwing money away
hey hey jocko i got to go to hey look i
don't need to hear your ideas right now
we need to move forward okay cool that
just cost me it's like everything we do
people just throw it away like it's
nothing they break they break out the
freaking they go into debt they go then
they end up bankrupt
leadership you ever met someone that has
no leadership capital left yes i have
yeah like you work for someone that's an
you work for someone that
doesn't listen to anybody else they have
no leadership capital yeah and and and
maybe they can make some things happen
early on because they have the authority
or they have the experience or they have
the position that that and that they can
actually make a little bit of progress
and then the leadership capital's gone
and everything just falls apart yeah and
that's like a uh back
and i've said this before so i don't
need to go too deep into it but the you
know how like you have an old boss that
you used to work for and he was just a
dick or whatever you don't work there
anymore you work at a better job now you
know and then maybe you see that old
boss somewhere the way you feel about
him
you can see his leadership capital is at
zero at that point that's zero
so that's what i'm gonna do i'm gonna
consider uh leadership capital and it's
gonna weigh very heavily and and by the
way the reason i didn't put this on the
list originally because it was so
it was so integral to the way i think i
didn't even see it there yeah you know i
mean it was one of those things it was
almost like if you if i was to put down
what do you need every day echo you'd be
like hey i need a good workout i need uh
to get a good steak i i want to roll jiu
jitsu and i but what about oxygen what
about air he'd be like well yeah
obviously that's leadership capital for
me was like breathing air it was that
integral to my day i didn't even see it
was there yeah so yeah now that you
bring it up though it's like it's not
like air right because it's so like
people don't
understand actually wrong it is like air
it is but they're ignoring it so it's
like that well it is but people don't
realize how valuable until they can't
breathe
so they don't even realize it's there
and they're they're like just wasting it
and it doesn't matter it'll always be
there no it's not
you get choked out
so what happens tell me you're not
concerned about air when you're getting
that guillotine choke sunk on you i am
concerned about air at that point real
concern yes so be careful tell me if you
think this is an uh example of
being in touch with leadership capital
so you know as you know we have this dog
now a small dog never wanted a dog i
didn't want a dog what's your dog's name
maya it's a small little wee what do you
call it yorkie i think i don't know what
you call because i don't have the gun
bro you know what it's called anyway one
of these little small ducks whatever
it's whatever it's cute whatever i never
wanted the dog though but why we're
gonna add another thing to the my simple
life
all the kids want dogs my wife maybe
maybe she wanted the dog maybe not but
she hears it from the kids every day oh
my gosh every time the kids see a dog
and there's people in our neighborhood
neighborhood with cool little dogs and
stuff and they're nice dogs and so
they're great examples of dogs all
around constantly being reminded how
they don't have a dog right
so finally i'm like hey all right i kind
of went through this loop a little bit
in a small way where i'm like hey you
know leadership capital at some point in
there exactly right so i'm like all
right now
this would be actually an interesting uh
thing for us to do is go through your
decision to get a dog and and and assess
your leadership loop on this thing right
i mean
you know time well you do have plenty of
time to make this decision so you didn't
like rush one week and be like okay we
need to get a dog now you know you took
time to consider it two years by the way
so there you go yeah cover move
you were like hey
if we don't get a dog is that putting me
first yes it is and so you kind of made
that decision like
gotta put the team first yeah simple
this is one one of those things we're
like well this is gonna actually make
things more complex so you had to put
that into the calculus right prioritize
and execute well is it one of our
priorities well we saw some family unity
being being
uh created and so that was a positive
thing so the priority kind of stepped up
a little bit because we want the family
to be tight and yeah and there's other
other elements in that too because
you know like okay so my daughter's nine
so getting a small dog too this is like
a small it's not like some big great
dane where it's like more responsibility
or whatever it's a small little dog
minimal arguably responsibility
comparatively speaking and you have a
pet that it actually is response
responsibility for the kid obviously
being supported by us of course you know
but she gets to learn a little bit of
that responsibility
sacrifice you know and stuff like that
so it was a net as far as priorities go
and the developmental elements of a kid
and let's face it like
is it unreasonable for a kid to have a
childhood pet is that unreasonable no no
it's good and as you just mentioned
there's lessons to be learned exactly
which goes into decentralized command
you know that
is this something you can decentralize
so did you go oh we're gonna get this
dog and then i'm gonna have to walk it
i'm gonna have to feed it um no you were
probably like hey i'm not cleaning up
dog
right i'm not going to be the one that
feeds it every now and then so you knew
you could decentralize some of this
stuff so that is
additionally positive here
was it your ego that was getting in the
way a little bit because hey check it
out
let's face it the dog is going to take a
little attention away from echo charles
just a little bit right and plus you
might have been like hey this is my
house yeah right you could get into that
mode and that that is um i'm not saying
you did but it could be a little bit
maybe not necessarily in that particular
way like he was my house and i make
through it wasn't that it was more about
like oh yeah everyone wants this dog but
what about what i want it was like that
and i was like bro that's kind of whack
you know when i realized that
good okay
um emotion
you had to at least check the emotion
that you were having
and that everyone else was having
because if you don't you you weighed in
how happy everyone was going to be
and that countered how like somewhat
frustrated you were gonna be you
actually went through this and thought
to yourself you know what
them being super happy outweighs me
being a little bit aggravated so you put
you did the calculus of the emotion made
the right call mission does this help
our mission as a family again helps
bring the family together there's
lessons to be learned we have something
to talk about we have uh uh what's that
a common
affection towards this thing you know
even though this thing is small and weak
and doesn't really protect us from
anything which is okay but it gets it
gets the kids outside even more right
you know all this stuff leadership cap
so this is where we get to so now you
got to a point where his leadership
capital you were and how did you
calculate that on the dog purchase which
in a small way went back to measuring
the emotions and comparing them but it
was essentially that like people
everyone knew that i didn't want a dog
in fact they've been knowing it for two
years i'm not the kind of person
whatever that that's like no you know
like i don't complain about that and
stuff but they everyone knew that i was
not really into it at all
um
when we got it i didn't be like yeah i
wasn't into it but i did it anyway for
you guys none of that kind of stuff i
was just kind of like i was like hey if
that's what we're doing let's do it and
i'm so actually i will clean up after it
as a priority yeah but i'm down for the
support 100
so
uh when
when it was time to to
get the dog or whatever i was like i
basically got on board
and i figured and i guess in terms of
leadership i wasn't thinking of it in
terms of leadership capital but i wasn't
thinking of it in terms of like hey what
would like what's the right thing to do
here
and something that
would if i get on board in a positive
way in a conducive way that's going to
be better off for everybody
so that's just what i did but kind of
maybe how should i say
inadvertently whatever just not thinking
thinking of it i'm sure that did because
people know that i didn't want the dog
but meanwhile i have a good attitude
about it i'm still cleaning up i think
let's face it this is the classic tale
right where the dad doesn't want the dog
then the dad ends up being the best
friend of the dog kind of a thing you
know
we're not quite there yet but i have
embraced the dog on a personal level
teeny tiny dog
check so i feel like
if they even notice who knows they're
little kids yeah you know they i
guarantee you've got some leadership
capital out of this guaranteed yeah and
that's good
because over time also you you got to
think how much am i spending leadership
capital when this is the one thing they
want and i'm not getting it for them
yeah that's that could be a problem
and as i i shouldn't even say like it
probably wouldn't actually be that big
of a problem and the reason it's not
that big of a problem because it's a
huge ask right it's a huge ask a dog is
a big deal man yeah you can't just be
getting a dog on a whim you need you
should go through this checklist
before you go and invest in a dog or
pick up a dog from the dog pound or
whatever you're gonna do
here's what i do have in mind
consciously in regards to leadership
capital if i complain about that doc or
about having the dog not even
necessarily about the dog yeah because
you can complain about like frick the
dog's barking you know whatever but
if i complain about having the dog yep
that is like to me it feels like i'm
like spending so much of that leadership
capital because it's like i never wanted
that dog you know making everyone feel
guilty or something like this never it's
it's uh against the straight-up
morals yeah that would be that's how
strict i think that would be bad so
leadership capital
put that in the calculus it's more
valuable than the air that you breathe
from a leadership perspective now
the next thing is as and i i've
mentioned just a bunch already
but as i'm judging or assessing all
these aspects of a decision i am going
to the whole time pay attention to my
own bias
yeah you know do i tend to think that i
have too much leadership capital because
there's people that are like that they
think oh hey man don't worry i'm joking
man people just go no
do i underestimate the amount of
leadership capital that i have
first of all that's rare and it's
usually not true
but those are things that i am going to
do
i am going to constantly be assessing my
own bias so you might want to throw onto
your leadership loop
bias assessment
to make sure that you're not making a
mistake because of the biases that you
have and or you can put or you can put
that into each one of these topics
ego emotion mission leadership capital
you can put bias into each one of those
subcategories to say yeah you know what
i know i'm always getting let my ego get
in the way or maybe you're saying the
other opposite side you know i'm never
confident enough with my decisions
on time right
what's your bias
do you think everything takes five
minutes when it really takes a half an
hour
calculate that bias
and then the last thing i'm going to say
here is
something that i like to think about
am i looking at the symptoms
or am i looking at the root cause
because
[Music]
a lot of times the solution that's right
in front of your face
is actually a solution to a symptom
and we see this like 2d
solution that's right in front of us and
it's usually obvious and here's what's
tricky it's usually right
usually the first you know if echo is
doing something or if we if we got to
come up with a plan and i come up with a
quick plan
to solve a problem usually that first
plan that we both see is a solution and
it will work
but there's a a good chance that we're
both reacting to a symptom and not to
the disease
so i like to just check myself
and say is what i'm looking at the
symptom
or is it or is it the actual root cause
of the problem and is the solution
that's being proposed or the plan i'm
coming up with is it a 2d solution for
something that's right in front of me or
is it a 3d that will actually get us a
long-term solution
so that's what i'm going to look at
now
here's what messes us up in this loop
and it's pretty similar to what can mess
you up in the ooda loop
number one is you can get stuck in any
one of these areas just like you get
stuck in the loop in the loop you can
get stuck observing you're just looking
around looking around trying to trying
to see what you see you're trying to get
every angle and you get stuck there you
get stuck looking around and you get
shot down
maybe you get stuck orienting yourself
you're like wait hold on where are they
where am i hold on let me see exactly
where i'm at you get shot down
maybe you get stuck in the decision but
wait should i go left should i go right
should i left go right i don't know
there's advantage it's going left
there's advantage going right you get
shot down
or act you just you won't take action
you don't do the action you get shot
down
so if you get stuck in any of these as
well same thing
if you get stuck
thinking about any of these things
and you let it become the focus i want
to make sure my ego is not a problem so
and that's what you focus on you don't
consider time you don't consider emotion
you don't consider the mission so you
can't get stuck on any of these things
you can't get stuck
you have to let the the loop continue to
flow and you know what you're going to
figure out you're going to figure out
that there's some things that you're
good at in this loop and there's
something that you're bad at
maybe your ego is not a problem
but you have a problem with time
maybe your emotion
isn't a problem but you always get
distracted by different missions
maybe
you cover and move really well but you
don't realize that you expend leadership
capital and stuff that doesn't matter
so you want to continually observe these
things and you want to over index on the
things that you know you you are weak at
so that's the number one way that we get
messed up when we're making decisions
the number two thing is we don't we
ignore the feedback that we're getting
which is such a disaster
it's such a disaster to ignore
the feedback that we're getting and you
know the the point i made earlier about
echo charles and how my eagle is going
to lie to me
your ego is lying a hundred percent of
the time let's let me just say that my
ego is is actually in this case choco
look i know i get it but this okay echo
really is the problem
he really is the problem
that
and when i ignore that the fact that i i
i'm sorry not that ignore but i let my
ego convince me that you know what this
time just this one time my ego is right
yeah it's not or just this one time hey
this is an emotional decision it's the
right thing to do you know jacko said
you need to put emotions into calculus
and i'm pissed so we're gonna do it no
we ignore feedback
and of course this comes from uh a lack
of humility
when you're being told something even in
your own head but you ignore it
like you know i know echo might kind of
get screwed by this decision but you
know he's not going to notice boom
you're just lying to yourself you're
ignoring the feedback
and that's going to cost you
and so in order to do that this comes
back to a fundamental
a fundamental skill of leadership that i
wrote about leadership strategy and
tactics and that is the ability to take
a step back and detach that's the only
way you're going to see this stuff you
can't
detachment is a superpower and the
reason that detachment is a superpower
is because the solution to the problem
is not in the problem
the solution to the problem will not be
found inside the problem you got to step
outside the problem in order to see the
solution don't get wrapped up in the
problem itself
instead
take a step back
run through this loop so you can make
better decisions
and what is an important thing to re
recognize
you might be thinking like oh well i'm
not you know the ceo of some big company
and i don't even need to make a bunch of
decisions guess what
life is a series of decisions
all day every day
that's what life is everything that you
do is a decision
it's it's almost like the the
binary decision which i wrote about in
this clinical freedom manual everything
that you do is a decision they're not
always necessarily binary but when you
live life you're making decisions
everything you do is a decision
so because everything you do is a
decision once you realize that you
should detach and you should have a
protocol for
making decisions because then your
decisions will be better
and you should have the humility to
realize
when you aren't making good decisions
and when you get that feedback and
realize oh i gotta make some different
decisions now
and then you make adjustments and you
make better decisions and you move on
but and what's beautiful about this
is it means
that if everything in your life is based
on the decisions you're making
guess what
you have a lot of control over your life
based on the decisions that you make
so make good decisions
it's going to make you a better person
it's going to make you a better leader
it's going to give you a better life
all right
there you go echo charles sir
speaking of good decisions i know
there's some ways that people could
decide to support themselves a little
bit better it's true
and they could support this podcast
while they're doing it it's true they
can support america while they're doing
it very true yeah which is kind of a big
deal yeah especially considering how
tenuous the world is right now world's
tenuous place sure there's other
elements out there making a move yeah
you know got china making a move they're
out there making a move yeah they're
trying to take the russia's out there
they're making a move yeah people are
stepping up
moves are being made moves are being
made and are we gonna sit back
now does this mean you need to pick up a
rifle and go to war no but i'll tell you
what you can do you can support america
mm-hmm i know a good way to do that yeah
me too well it starts with ourselves
right i think a lot of the times
about good decisions where look other
people are not making decisions for you
unless you're letting them
but you want to make good decisions for
yourself right i would imagine so it
starts with yourself
we're uh
take caring taking care of ourselves
physically mentally
deciding to that's what we're doing it's
true yeah
yeah so we're working out of course 100
we're reading
you know that yes we are we should be at
the very least listen wait are you
reading you know i'm reading here and
there bro i don't know about this wait a
second here what are you reading
um well there was okay so there's a
because you can't reference mind games
which you read nine years ago yeah and
that's not i think that may be the only
book you've ever referenced since i've
known you oh i don't know
okay what do we got what's on the what's
on the docket echo charles all right
most of them i'm gonna tell you what's
currently on the docket because they'd
have to you know but wait a second bro
you can be honest we're telling each
other the truth this is like leadership
uh you know uh uh capital we're trying
to build but if you're not gonna tell me
like oh no no right now i'm not reading
anything because you know it's
summertime and i was in hawaii yeah so
we're not reading anything unless you
are yes so what are we reading right now
nothing or this book so it depends
because that's a spectrum
you should own this a hundred percent
right now otherwise it's not gonna lose
here's the 100 uh uh truth on the matter
so
i have kindle books and audio books like
you know some are halfway done some are
all done some whatever so when
how much time has to be elapsed between
the last time i was into one of these
books actually like reading it or
listening to it
to now how much time has to pass before
i'm technically
not reading let's just say
a week
okay
we might not be reading
but all right that being said that's
kind of a bummer that means that the
books that you're reading or even
listening to
must not be that captivating uh or
well yeah i mean i guess in a matter of
speaking technically yeah but that
doesn't mean that they're not
captivating that might mean that other
things that i'm doing they're competing
with life and life is life is
captivating which is a good thing yes
sir right but the last thought of that
comeback you know some people are i'm
reading three books a week be like oh
that's cool
i'm actually living
yeah right that could be a little bit of
a dichotomy could be yes and obviously
that's going to depend because reading
three books a week one we don't know how
fast they read or listen or whatever or
what they're doing you know what if
they're going on miles runs we're doing
the same thing you know it's kind of a
you know so it can be an awesome it can
be kind of what you're alluding to where
it's like what if i'm flexing though
that's fine oh wait flexing with the i'm
reading that's just a flex like
like uh
fourth book i've read this month right
right just to sort of bring this
like yeah well you know there are very
many variations of flexing because it'd
be an interesting reflex would be like
i don't have time to read books yeah
or that could be an excuse okay excuse
me yeah so it just depends it's a
dichotomy okay so where where is ecuador
charles the last book that i expected
the last book that i finished which was
recently um i don't know whatever fema
actually i read it twice so
uh was the four agreements recommended
by jason
yeah that's a good one and you guys i
heard you guys talking about it and you
seemed uh both you know you were both
concurred that it was good yeah and a
lot of times that that type of book and
i mean this type that type of book in
this particular particular way is it's
real like um
like it has a lot of spiritual like
terms you know but
and you know usually spiritual terms are
real like
they land on different people in
different ways i'm not tracking
spiritual terms i.e what what's a
spiritual term like um you know calling
things black magic or because he'll use
that term a lot yeah but he's he's using
those terms because i i heard you guys
talking about and i think i might have
even been talking to you a little bit
about it or jason
those are just like an analogy like this
type of attitude is black magic that's
negative yes right so i took it in that
way okay
like it's not like he was literal black
man magic yeah and every once in a while
it kind of felt like that but either way
i never took it as that like to me
that's not the useful part of it um the
useful part is many other things but
anytime they say something like black
magic i know what he's saying i know
what you mean i think i do anyway i
believe i do so i i just i put it that
way i
took it in that way um but yeah so that
being said the spiritual parts even with
those spiritual parts or whatever like
what he was saying with all the four
agreements is like very it was really
it's a good one it's a good one and
a lot of it might not come as like a
surprise like oh man i totally didn't
know that but just like a lot of books
about like ways to think and regard
yourself in the world and stuff it's
like oh okay that's that makes sense or
that's a good reminder you know it's
kind of like what we just covered
there's a lot of people that are like oh
of course you should consider if you're
screwing over your your buddy yeah yep
and it seems obvious
but
there's times that people do this aware
unaware and i think the big warning
there is like you think no one notices
everyone else so yeah some things can be
actually i think when something seems
obvious usually that's affirming to like
this this has got to be this is pretty
true
because i know i felt this way and now
i'm seeing this guy felt this way and
now i you know so it becomes like a
thing yeah
and sometimes it just puts certain
things certain elements into perspective
that you might not have realized how
important they are or how prevalent they
are in day-to-day you know stuff
awareness yeah when you're aware of
things you become
just awareness is a is a huge step up in
understanding and
reacting properly and interacting
properly with the world
like the idea that you actually brought
up a few times today uh the idea that
like people notice
like what like well i see what you're
doing or i see whether it be your
intention or when they're getting
screwed over whatever like the idea that
people can see what's going on that i
think that's
one of the many things that's like
it helps to understand how big of a
thing that is like you know how it's
like yeah sometimes they'll notice
sometimes they won't it kind of feels
like that sometimes they know this oh
yeah people know it like you know how
and i've said this before i got it from
sam harris where it's like nate when you
name drop someone it's like bro everyone
sees you name dropping and it's not even
like a noble thing you mean when you
talk about i got this from sam harris oh
yeah
after we hung out this one day you know
it was awesome but
but that's like you know one of the many
examples of
sure maybe somebody caught it but you
know i'm sure it was effective when i
did it but everyone noticed the same way
you'll notice when someone else does it
you know it's kind of one of those
things
but um
and there's a lot of things like that
you know um so yeah that i think that
book overall was a lot of that um but
some stuff was like oh that is a good
way to look at things yeah and and
sometimes when somebody's written
something out and they've explained it
it clarifies it for you it
increases your understanding and the
better understanding you have
then the more
you can interact with that properly you
can utilize that as a tool yeah that's
good stuff so
uh yeah we want to read
very on varying levels yeah
because i'm reading one book a week over
here
yeah that's good if you're reading one
book a week that's good man yeah
it's hard to say that that's bad yeah i
uh uh i don't actually know if i there
was a while when i was reading one book
every week when we were doing the
podcast it was like almost all books
yeah
and then it seemed like we went a little
a bunch of people were coming on for
interviews
um so that was a little bit more
interview centric so but i
this i can say
there is no period of time of more than
two days where i haven't read something
no damn yeah so
that's kind of where i'm at but that's
not a flex bro cause guess what maybe i
should be uh you know surfing or
getting in fights at uh rei sure hell
yeah situations
he
if you don't know he's surfer and a jiu
jitsu guy and an awesome guy but uh
he like posted something something about
like basically kook servers
like you know
surfer starter kit malibu surfer starter
kit and one of the pictures was like a
sprinter
i responded on this post i was like hey
bro i got a sprinter yeah yeah yeah so
sorry joel sorry joel i got a sprinter
there people well so it's kind of a
confirmation really in a small way oh
sorry they call me a kook huh
that's messed up
i was up on the horses and i asked the
guys the cow the actual cowboys i said i
said hey in surfing if you're if you
don't know how to surf but you have a
surfboard and you're paddling out but
you have no idea what you're doing
then you're a kook
i said what's that called on horseback
riding
and because that's me because i don't
know how to ride a horse
and they said uh it's a dude
so there's a thing called a dude ranch
which is basically for city slickers to
go out and like be a cowboy for a little
while i didn't know that and so if
you're one of those people
then you are a dude that's weird i've
heard of dude
there's another word that they told me
as well but i can't remember it
yeah
it's funny but i was one of those i am
one of those on a horse your dude yeah
that's funny there was a show called hey
dude
and it was about a dude ranch and it was
i think it was on like nickelodeon or
something
in the day well hey man learn something
new every day see sometimes you don't
even have to read you just come listen
to
jackal being a dude
or whatever you're being over there
um but we are working out every day yes
yes
like currently working out
like you can make that claim you don't
have to you don't have to sort of put
put explanations around that claim
bro your face was so guilty when you
said you read i was like dude please
don't lie
i was trying to i was trying to do the
calculus because that's a legitimate
question because like if you say oh i'm
working out right but you haven't worked
out in two weeks you're like bro you're
not working out yeah you're currently
not working out actually but if it's
been like two days that's like okay you
could have just been coming off a rest
weekend or something like this and
you're still on the program saying or
working out so with reading how is that
i never thought about it so look if i
read last night before i went to bed or
something easy right i know the answer
oh i'm reading this last night i was
reading this but let's face it it's been
three weeks
so that was three weeks it's kind of a
gift isn't it
yeah ah
it yeah yeah i'm gonna agree with you
kind of a gift yeah
we're giving you the opportunity to tell
the truth wait wait what do you mean
three weeks as a gift i'm saying me
saying oh you you were reading three
weeks ago you were reading oh yeah yeah
it's kind of me being not generous yeah
technically i don't know i've never done
the the math and the technical you know
evaluation but if you compare it to work
you can never get interrogated
if you compared to working out then no
i'm not reading currently not
but here's the thing too though did you
already lift today no no yeah
this afternoon squats today by the way
okay
uh either with the mental prep going
yeah a little bit um but here's the
thing about reading versus working out
you can pick up a book for like 10
minutes you can read three pages
working out if i go do one two sets of
curls is that a workout
i know it's btn i know i know btn is
better than nothing yeah which is a
non-philosophy in my opinion but that's
just just my opinion
how about this we'll use that philosophy
very sparingly how about that all right
but you see what i'm saying though yes
you can read
a short amount and it still is providing
legitimate benefits yeah and progress
yeah whereas
two sets of curls yeah well it is btn if
you believe in that philosophy which
echo doesn't
i would say it actually is btn it is
better than nothing yeah but if i go two
sets of girls and then now i say you
know what that's going to be my workout
routine bro after about two months it's
kind of like a end
nothing
i'm not speaking so
okay
look we got to the bottom of it thank
you jaco for your input
we're hopefully reading we're hopefully
working out we're hopefully uh improving
ourselves so we can deal with the world
in a better way to make better decisions
right right so get some jack-o-fuel
jackalfield.com get yourself some more
get yourself some hey this is this is of
all the things we're going to say about
jackal fuel the flavors of the
discipline go drinks
have been radically
upgraded
they were based on my taste buds before
my taste buds are not normal my taste
buds weren't appropriate to judge the
taste of a drink for the world
had to run that through the leadership
decision loop
and say wait my perspective on this is
not correct
other people have a more
a better palette for the job and we also
want something that's more universally
loved so we redid all the flavors
all the flavors are now awesome you may
have had one flavor that you really like
before and you might have two that you
just like these are gross
now you will at least
like all the flavors
and there will be
three and maybe five of them that you
love
yeah i would say so really true totally
redid them all uh they taste delicious
if you tried them when they were based
on my palate i apologize
um i'm taking ownership of the fact that
i had a very sensitive palette to
sweetness and a little bit of sweetness
tasted like sugar cane in my mouth and
that wasn't the truth
besides so we made them better you just
drink water though pretty much that's
what i'm saying that's why my palate was
so jacked and now and recently i got on
the water train so the only thing that i
drink is
water
every once in a while i'll have like a
monk
shake actually i have that more but even
now
everything is way sweeter everything if
you just drink water before i have an
occasional gatorade here maybe some you
know the kids got some orange well
that's a good example too
mango i didn't like your mango flavor
of discipline go
mango mayhem and now it tastes really
good
it's still not my favorite of the group
but i will definitely
enjoy drinking it so we're good yep i
feel like we're good too so there you go
get out here and get you some of that um
also we got the hunt gear coming
origin usa.com
get yourself some american-made hunt
gear and listen
that's just that's just what we have to
do in the world right now there's like i
said there's people that are stepping up
people that are not good and they're
stepping up and they're trying to take
over and you don't need to necessarily
pick up a rifle to go to war
but right now it's an economic war and
if you pick up some origin usa gear
it's going to help us win the war so we
have to fight a war that's the goal
let's be economically strong
so go to originusa.com get a ghee
because you should be training you too
just in case the war does come
get some hunt gear
just in case the war does come you can
hunt the enemy but in the meantime you
can hand
deer elk whatever else it is you want to
hunt get yourself some of that um also
we have a store don't we have a store we
do okay what's that all about it's
called jaco store you want to represent
like we're uh you know improving
ourselves making good decisions you want
to represent discipline equals freedom
which is kind of the overarching kind of
thing for this whole thing
more discipline you are the more freedom
you are anyway you want to represent
we've got some cool shirts and hats and
hoodies and what not some merch but it's
better than just merch though by the way
a lot of thought and effort and careful
meticulous
consideration has been put into all
these elements you should put that into
every
package that you send out just let
everybody know that careful time
consideration has been put into this oh
yeah
but and it's true there are many people
when i say many i mean for a countless
people that have said these like this
called the shirts and stuff like it's my
favorite shirt the new shirt that you
have on right now
this is this is called the standard
issue yeah right this one includes
freedom standard issue
so it's a new one
and there's a there's multiple color
ways color ways yeah you might write you
might recognize the um you know the
colors and what they represent but if
you don't like this kind of layer there
yes people need to figure out what the
layers mean yep simple but maybe not
easy kind of a thing i actually didn't
figure out you guys told me i may have
figured out if i would have maybe seen
them all at the same time and done a
consideration yeah i might have figured
it out but i didn't i didn't figure it
out but also i looked at him for like
three seconds i was like alright you
tell me well when you looked at the one
you were like that's what that is and
then all all you have to do is apply
that same thinking to all of them you'd
be like oh i see what's going on here
but yeah but either way layers there for
sure but if you don't if you don't know
layers it doesn't it doesn't even matter
you just choose the color that you like
or the colors and then if you do
understand the layers and it kind of
matters too yes sir it doesn't matter if
you don't get them but if you get them
it kind of does matter yeah let's face
it because if you listen you know
this is the way i see it this one is
kind of like this
what we call it standard issue it's kind
of like the main one
we're positioning as kind of the main
disciplinary stream the standard if you
have this one you're you're that's the
standard you have the standard issue yep
like if you don't have it like are you
even in the game or what i'm not saying
you're not
but you see what i'm saying there's a
question you don't have the standard
issue is what i'm saying
all right there you go so yeah
calm we also have the short locker don't
forget about that subscription one shirt
a new shirt
one month there new different designs a
little bit more creative i would say
um those are pretty good ones coming out
yeah you gave me a brief on the one
that's coming out yeah i'll say uh it's
it's affirmative yeah
it's good is that next when's that how
far out is that um
so august september september oh that's
a good one for september all right
awesome uh subscribe to the podcast you
know that at jackonground.com we've been
putting some out there if you want to
get some questions to us we'll respond
to those directly
and it's also given us the ability to
have our own platform to make sure that
whenever we get banned from this one
which could happen at any time
or they might just say hey from now on
when you listen to this podcast we're
going to insert our own advertisements
in here
so we don't like that that's why we made
jockwoodground.com so if you want to
subscribe to that
uh youtube channel if you want to see
awesome assistant directing
from me
sure you can check out that and i'll get
you covered down
thanks thanks psychological warfare on
mp3 flipsidecanvas.com dakota meyer i've
written a bunch of books about
leadership check them out
only cry for the living by holly holly
mckay that's a jocko publishing
she wrote that book she risked her life
to go write that book
so
she's been on the podcast the book is
is insane to read and will teach you
about the world and about evil in the
world
so
check that out we also have that
salonfront leadership consultancy
echelonfront.com if you want me to come
and talk to your company
let us know
ashlandfront.com if you need help we can
help you if you want to go to any events
that i've been talking about things like
the muster things like the council
things like ef battlefield
just just come and check those the next
ef battlefield is sold out but it's that
little bighorn looking at that looking
forward to that
i think the next muster is in atlanta
hotlanta october 12th the 14th
we sell out everything so if you want to
come get there quick and also we have
the online training academy i mentioned
that a couple times today
teaching
people how to
lead in their life and a lot of times
people think oh you know i don't need to
learn how to lead i'm only in charge of
three people or i don't know how to lead
because i'm not even in charge of anyone
guess what you are in charge of someone
you you're making decisions all the time
you have a family you have peers that
you need to lead you have to lead your
boss i know that seems crazy
so go to extremeownership.com
if you want to get in on that online
training
part of the reason we built that is to
make it more accessible to more people
that's the mission of echelon front to
pass on the leadership lessons we
learned
and
the lead the echelon front team can't
get to everybody
but now we can extremeownership.com go
and check it out and if you want to help
service members active and retired you
and help their families you want to help
gold star families check out mark lee's
mom
mama lee she's got an incredible charity
organization where she provides most of
most of what she does
she does a bunch of things
i would say that the best thing that she
does well i would say the best thing
uh how can i say this
one of the most impactful things that
she does and she does a lot of impactful
things is she provides
medical
help
for veterans
that
is not provided for by the veterans
administ administration
so
hyperbaric chamber is one of the primary
things she does to take someone that's
having issues
and pay for them to go
to a location where they have a
hyperbaric chamber put them on the right
nutrition
give them the right vitamins
get their get their health squared away
for 30 days everything's paid for
30 days of
recovery from the impact of combat and
trauma that's one of the things that she
does
so that's at america's
mightywarriors.org
so check that one out and then of course
i was talking about being on a horse
today and i'm a dude sure meaning i'm
not skilled
but
you can
when you're out there in the wilderness
and you're interacting with an animal
and you're in the open air
it's it's a very
positive thing
for your mental and physical health so
micah fink he has this thing called
heroes and horses at heroes and
horses.org
he takes veterans
into the wilderness for 41 days
and it's horseback
it's camping it's staying out on the
trail
and guys are coming back
renewed
and reanimated for life so check out
heroes and horses.org he's been on the
podcast i'm sure we'll get him back on
here again at some point but he's got a
great charity as does mama lee so check
those things out if you want to support
and if you want to check in with us
we're on social media on twitter on the
gram on facebook
that goes out echo charles i'm at
jacqueline hey listen and if you're
gonna go on there all i'm saying is be
careful
because there's an algorithm that's
looking to grab you by the throat don't
let it
be ready for it don't let it run your
life get off your phone
and of course to all those military
folks out there in the world that are
making decisions
every day
that provide us freedom and security
thank you for what you do
and also thanks to
police and law enforcement and
firefighters and paramedics and emts and
dispatchers and correctional officers
and border patrol and secret service and
all the first responders
thank you for protecting our freedom and
security
here at home
and everyone else out there life is
all decisions and everything you do
is based on decisions that you make
so think about the process and and think
about the amount of control that these
decisions give you over your own life
and think about the impact that these
decisions have in your life so don't
just let them happen
make them happen
make them happen by being aware of your
decisions and make them happen by having
a protocol so you make the right
decisions to do the right things so you
can be a better leader a better person
and lead a better life
and until next time this is echo and
jocko
out